rational exponents rational just means a
ratio like a fractional exponent right
but they call them rational exponents
and the main thing is that the numerator
is the power okay and the denominator is
the root took a that's that's index here
so if an was 2 that would be the square
root if n is 3 that would be the cube
root now if you have a negative exponent
thrown in there you want to remember
negative exponents to take the
reciprocal or you can think of moving it
to the other side of the fraction bar
and then making it a positive exponent
so the negative flips it but again the
denominators of the root and the
numerator is the power now you can see
there's two different ways to do this
one way is to take the power first in
the root second the other way to do this
is to take the root first and the power
second it sounds confusing but let's
look at a couple examples and try to
simplify this for us so 8 to the 2/3 the
way I like to do this to make it simple
is do the root part first so this means
the cube root of 8 now the reason I'm
doing that is because it makes the
number smaller so what is the cube root
of 8 that's going to be 2 because 2
times 2 times 2 2 cubed is 8 and then
you want to raise it to the second power
so this is 2 squared which equals 4 ok
let's look at another example
27 to the negative 2/3 okay see that
negative that negative says take the
reciprocal okay and then raise it to the
positive 2/3 okay now again that
denominator see that 3 that means the
cube root of 27 right and then the
quantity squared so that what number
times itself 3 times is 27 that's going
to be 3 so we have 1 over 3 squared
which equals 1 over 9 now the other way
to do this problem is just ignore the
negative for a moment take the cube root
of 27 which is 3 3 squared is 9 and then
take the reciprocal and that gives us
the 1/9 now how to use this in equations
when you're solving equations well the
easiest way to do this is just to raise
both sides to the reciprocal power so
you can see I'm cubing this let's just
raise both sides to the 1/3 power okay
because power to power you multiply 3
times 1/3 just gives you 1 so you get X
plus 2 equals 41 to the one-third now
I'm going to use the calculator here and
kind of see what that comes out to for
us so we've got let's see 41 raised to
the 1/3 power
and that comes out to 3.45 so we'll just
say three point four or five and then
I'm going to subtract two from both
sides and you can see that X is coming
out to one point four five and